how did a raccoon get so smart is
romance in the future for Peter Quill
and who's guarding the Galaxy by the
time Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 comes
to a close spoilers ahead
space it's huge but not so huge that the
aliens ever look all that different from
humans apparently as has always been the
case in the MCU half the species and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 are
basically regular people with face paint
and a lot of them didn't even check into
hair and makeup many of the extras on
nowhere and even the high evolutionary
himself all appear to be earthlings yet
they aren't again this isn't anything
new for the franchise but it feels
particularly strange this time around
the high evolutionary is clearly not
from Earth though he is in the comics as
he talks about having visited the planet
once and yet he appears to be a normal
man and he crafts his counter Earth in
its namesake's image even fills it with
evolved versions of Earth animals there
are fan theories that have tried to
explain this away but the real answer
unfortunately is probably just ease of
production It's Not Unusual for Sci-Fi
movies to fill half the Galaxy with
humans as any Star Wars fan will tell
you but then again Earth doesn't exist
in Star Wars so it doesn't feel quite so
strange a little more makeup would have
gone a long way toward the cosmic World
building of the MCU but volume 3 also
had a chance to explain all the humans
in a way that connects to the story
instead their presence remains a mystery
over the course of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 Rocket's whole tragic
backstory is revealed the film opens
with a shot of him as a baby raccoon in
a cage the only one of his litter who
faces is captors when they come instead
of turning this back piece by piece we
see him be experimented on learn to
speak grow older make friends and
ultimately lose them at the hands of the
high evolutionary perhaps the most
Curious Thing revealed in the flashbacks
however is just how special rocket
actually is as a kid he identifies a
huge flaw on the high evolutionaries
bioengineering Tech thanks to his Keen
Eye the process is fixed then the
villains plan for a perfect species
moves forward unfortunately Rocket's
technical Brilliance also puts a Target
on his back the high evolutionary
becomes obsessed with Rocket's
intelligence he can't understand how a
being he created could have found a
problem he himself couldn't identify the
whole thing could be written off his
rocket Simply Having a sharp Mechanical
Mind but is there something more going
on here a high evolutionary has created
countless creatures and tested them all
in various ways if rocket truly is the
only one to ever generate such an
original idea that makes him incredibly
unique with the film stopped short of
explaining why that's the case the
Guardians saved rocket from his Grievous
injuries but just barely by the time
Star-Lord and Gamora upload the passkey
that allows him to receive medical
treatment he's already got one foot on
the other side this leads to a curious
scene in which rocket talks to Lila his
fellow test subject former friend and
implied love interest and a white boy
essentially she tells him that she's in
a Heavenly paradise and that there are
other friends who died are also there
Rocket says he wants to join them but
she reminds him that he can't just yet
because he still has work to do in the
land of the living the big question here
of course is what's actually going on is
this a true vision of the afterlife or
is it merely a hallucination in Rocket's
mind a delusion caused by his near-death
experience and me and my friends are
gonna go flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
aside from its core character arcs
pulling heavily from Avengers Infinity
war and end game Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 doesn't connect much to the rest
of the MCU that ends up working to its
benefits as the film feels more
independent and less like a Nexus point
for cameos and future setups however
there are times when it feels downright
ah on how separate the story is there
are no references to the Multiverse no
chaos magic and hardly any nods to pace
for period if more Curious is a lack of
reference to Thanos or rather a nebula
and Gamora reference Thanos because he
was their father but there are no real
allusions to the snap when Thanos use
The Infinity Gauntlet he didn't just
wipe out half of all sentient life on
Earth he did it everywhere you'd think
that would have an effect on someone
trying to create whole new species and
societies but the high evolutionary
never brings it up to be fair the
infinity Saga is over and the MCU simply
may not be interested in dealing with it
any longer but it would have been
interesting and relevant to hear how the
snap impacted the high evolutionaries
plans he's obsessive with his work and
sees himself as a God how do they make
him feel when half of all his
experiments vanished in an instant
a high evolutionary is a Despicable
villain but he gets his comeuppance in
the end his subordinates rebel against
him the Guardians destroy his ship and
when rocket finally confronts him the
raccoon takes him down the thing is
rocket chooses not to land a killing
blow on his Tormentor he's a guardian of
the galaxy not a killer and he chooses
to help get all the animals out instead
a high evolutionary is in rough shape
when they leave him and his ship
completely explodes soon after it seems
impossible that he could have survived
but without a definitive Kill Shot we
can't say for sure could he return to
the MCU in the future of course he could
Willie probably not he has no connection
to the big picture plot phase five and
it doesn't seem like he'd have a reason
to go up against any other notable
Marvel heroes since there are no plans
at the moment for a fourth Guardians of
the Galaxy movie that would seem to
quash any chance of a high evolutionary
Revenge story
if you went into Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 expecting Star-Lord and the new
Gamora to get back together you might be
a little disappointed right now though
the two share some tender moments Gamora
never quite returns to her old self
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
she emphasizes repeatedly that she can
only be the person she is now one with a
very different set of experiences and
perspectives on the world though she
reconnects with the other Guardians and
befriends them again by the end of the
movie she never actually rejoins the
team in the final moments of volume 3
Gamora returns to her new ravager family
where she's welcomed with revelry and
open arms but before she leaves she does
Express a bit of regret that she can't
be the person who once left Peter again
could these two crazy kids ever figure
it out it's possible who knows what wild
Cosmic circumstances might bring them
crashing back together down the line
however because Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 feels like such a definitive
endpoint a reunion for quill and Gamora
seems unlikely the whole movie has a
theme of growing beyond your worst
moments of letting the past go to
embrace the future Peter accepting that
his Gamora is gone is a big part of that
message and it would cheapen the story
to undo it by the end of Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 the population of
nowhere has grown exponentially refugees
of all species from the high
evolutionary ship now called loading
head home and they have a Fearless new
leader in nebula the blue skinned cyborg
who once wanted nothing more than to
murder and Destroy has become the mayor
of space town and she fits the job
surprisingly well nebula arguably has
the biggest Arc of any of the main
characters and she feels more like the
leader through volume 3 than Star-Lord
she even recruits Drax to help her build
the new city of nowhere under their
guiding hands nowhere seems destined for
great things or at least peace but what
exactly this new Society will look like
remains unclear nowhere is naturally
nomadic so could it become a rescue
vessel for other refugees and people in
need well all of the high evolutionaries
prisoners remain there or will nebula
embark on a great mission to return them
all to the rightful homes and perhaps
most importantly will nowhere pop up
again in the MCU floating through the
cosmos only time will tell the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 script finally
treats mantis as an equal with the
others and she shines in the spotlight
but when all said and done she decides
to split off from the group and travel
alone for a while she says that her
whole life she's only follow followed
others and that it's time for her to
forge her own path and discover what she
actually wants out of life it's a nice
moment for a character who's usually
caught up in other people's emotional
lives but it's unknown where she'll go
to be fair even mantis doesn't know
where her journey will take her that's
kind of the point after being freed from
ego and traveling the Galaxy with the
Guardians she finally has a chance to
discover things in her own way in her
own time could she pop up in another
space set Marvel movie later on in Phase
five or Beyond almost certainly plus
since Star-Lord mantis are half siblings
I'll always have a reason to reunite
judging from the film's post-credits
scene it seems that Peter will be
sticking around in the MCU for a while
longer and mantis could be a part of
that next Arc it's not just mantis who
goes her own way at the end of Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 3. by all definitions
of the phrase the squad breaks up
Star-Lord returns to Earth to reconnect
with his grandfather nebula and Drax
stay on nowhere to lead the community
there and build the new city and Gamora
returns to the ravagers a new team is
formed led by rockets and composed of
craglin Cosmo the space doll Adam
Warlock is pet blurp and Groot one of
the kids from the high evolutionary ship
credited his Phila also joins a gang
given her name and superhuman abilities
it's likely that she's actually the
powerful filipel from the comics this
new team is plenty of fun but it's hard
not to wonder if the original Guardians
will ever properly reunite it would be
simple enough to get nebula Drax rocket
and group back together as a new team
likely still hangs out of nowhere and
Star-Lord will surely return to action
sooner or later after a well-earned
break back home but with James Gunn now
leading DC cinematic efforts and the MCU
moving into new territory there's no
guarantee that we'll ever see the
original Guardian Squad together again
are you ready
for one last ride
[Music]
after a brief post-credits scene of
Star-Lord relaxing with his grandfather
back on earth a final message promises
that the character will be back in the
MCU naming Peter in particular would
seem to suggest that the other Guardians
are gone for now which makes sense their
stories have all wrapped up for the most
part and they they've gone their
separate ways but while there may not be
another Guardian to the Galaxy Movie
Star Lord's run is not yet done there
are a number of places where quill could
pop up in the future the Marvels will
feature another Cosmic MCU story and
anywhere there are aliens Star-Lord
could appear we don't know much yet
about Captain America new world order
but that can also be an upcoming venue
for a Star-Lord Cameo since Peter is
back on Earth he could easily fall into
whatever Shenanigans Sam Wilson gets up
to next alternatively Star-Lord could be
held in reserve for one of the next big
MCU crossover events like the impending
secret War series or Avengers the Kang
Dynasty it's impossible to know for sure
but the former ravager from Missouri
will be back sooner or later
[Music]
thank you